That's why I came to have a future and to
leave behind all the suffering we've
been through
today, another caravan is planned to
reach the border of Guatemala with
Mexico. The Master X Treme explodes, but
hey, Steinmeier.
Let's be migrants, it doesn't
mean that we are criminals,
well, I do know that crime, but since we are
going to get it out of the money for clothes,
much more
[Music]
and
because we all have the right to look for
something better, there is
not much to survive from, to
stay is  what is there and is what you
have to do when your friends are
murdered people appear they begin to
organize with the means they have
I hope that my life
in fear will
no longer take away my mind
[Music]
[Applause]